c'est un endroit incontournable à
visiter pour tout candidat 100 59 ans
d'histoire et de fierté pour une
communauté dans quelques heures s'ouvre
la foire agricole de richmond nos
politiciens parlent toujours de
l'économie mondiale on réalise vite ici
que beaucoup de monde dépend de
l'industrie laitière et que la nervosité
s'est installé avec la crainte de voir
disparaître la gestion de l'offre second
plus gros des problèmes car on fait ça
par jose de crétins et ont beaucoup plus
récents on est bien loin des priorités
des centres urbains mais un peu tout le
monde ici a sa petite idée sur un des
enjeux qui vient d'enflammer les débats
politiques
l'accueil des réfugiés syriens il ya des
travailleuses à temps ci avec damas par
et des sucres sont au québec
sans s'éloigner dans un coin de pays où
l'immigration est quasi invisible
certains restent tiède face à la cause
d'immigrants on a très peur de bouger
par par tous temps par lui demander de
travailler fait le travail
j'arrive en sommes en état des émigrés
et nous la question des migrants a beau
avoir dominé la campagne ces derniers
jours
ce n'est pas nécessairement cet enjeu
qui va déterminer leur choix
le 19 octobre ici mark bourez au canada
richement